[Music]
where's Delia's crystally has [ __ ]
had it with Brendan he's already had it
now who is he is he the wing or the
sting or the king he's the swing The
Sting is
the king is gone the King was Theo yeah
I think this thing is Brandon
maybe I got that wrong isn't the wing
Eric the Eric Griffin guy who's Eric
Griffin the crystalia was the wing I
don't know man
so it's the king this thing the wing and
the token
I guess okay I mean and using the color
schemes and the symbols they use they
might as well just make it they might as
well just turn it into a Buffalo Wild
Wings I already got some of the letters
you got some of the logo there it'd be
more profitable
oh my God that's where Brendan came up
with the idea for the name of the show a
Buffalo Wild Wings because the wings
there's no way he didn't the king and
the sting are the Buffalo Wild Wings
[Laughter]
this is [ __ ] great yeah with uh that
girl is a good actor
I know what you're talking about and
then it ends spoiler they end up killing
the mom the boyfriend and the girl
killed the mom okay true story it's with
the Patricia pictures yes God that feels
good friends god it feels too good
really good man
dude
he [ __ ] hates Brandon now too
well I happen to body language is so
weird well because you sent that I
decided to just pull the episode up
nothing nothing
money also implies someone is successful
confident someone is a go-getter so
women don't like that at all yeah that's
what I'm saying they follow through but
that's what it implies that's awesome
because it's the ugly guys it's the
insecure guys on the internet will be
like oh she's only with you for your
money yeah no it's not money you know
what I mean because you you're you're no
no but I would say there are chicks oh
whoa yeah but that that yeah but they're
sure they're sugar babies oh no oh no
you're paying for that yeah yeah trust
me don't start saying Sugar Babies in in
front of [ __ ] Delia he'll start he'll
start sweating profusely
it's not a good feeling to like think
that you have to pay for things right
and it's not a good feeling to feel
okay sorry 27 and I live in
Ohio
this is my shittiest way to this great
Eric Griffin get to just show up late
yeah he's he's the wing
you're really gonna boost
so the new king is Delia
yeah
he's [ __ ] winging it
no he's the wing because they needed
somebody to come in for all the time
steel Von stopped coming in the real
reason real reason honestly that's why
he's there
I seen a [ __ ] somebody posted like on
one of the Theos read it that there's a
clip of [ __ ] Theo Von like like right
like a couple days before he was like
I'm I'm you know this is the last show
bitching that he couldn't get a word in
edgewise and then like that was the
moment that like ever like after that I
can't find the [ __ ] clip
well then why tell us all that till you
find it I I you know you're right I'm a
piece of [ __ ] I'm sorry the thing is
right is that Theo Vaughn was the king
yes and Brandon's job was the sting yes
so like get the king off that's it the
king left so she's just like it should
be the sting in the wing yeah
it should be the sting in the wing and
then when deleting in the bong and the
boom it should be the sting in the wing
and the diddler or whatever yeah true
you know what I mean they don't want to
do the extra work that it takes to
[ __ ] you know what I said I get that
I got I need the rooms joined and they
go we can't do that
yeah yeah okay no but I I I'm just
saying it's like yeah so I would be in a
hotel I don't care where I'm going I
like being in a hotel but if I'm
with my friends by the way too though I
don't know if I wanna like he needs a he
would be good for adjoining rooms
because he wants his yeah but like
sometimes
why are you just saying things he's a
good time no he's saying that if you
like travel with him he would ask for
adjoining rooms with whoever the other
comic he's traveling with because he's a
good time
okay he's fun
I don't want to be on the even on the
same floor like if we go someplace it's
like to say that's yeah more than a
joint vacation yeah wise right yeah I
don't want to be near you no yeah we
just found out he's a serial killer but
yeah yeah yeah uh you know floor ten you
on the left I I understand yeah he
doesn't want us judging them no I get I
don't need to be I don't need to be
adjoined yeah I I like I'm thinking
about when I go on what's up with all
these La Comics dressing homeless like I
don't even understand this anymore this
[ __ ] guy's got his foot up on the
table I I don't I don't I think you just
don't understand like cool La kinda like
culture yeah is it culture because like
I don't know man crystally has a neck
tattoo now that's kind of [ __ ] weird
was that new I haven't watched the guy
in a while but like is isn't that tattoo
a new thing for Crystal here yeah I I
don't know maybe he's going he's gone to
the Cody Rhodes School of trying to
become a baby face
oh my God
oh my God instead of [ __ ] dating
women that have baby faces yeah I'm with
you we're all done with the
bro I Love Gone With the Wind bee
yo papa papa
frankly my dear I don't give a [ __ ] bro
remember that line you misquotes it
knowing him he would misquote it too yo
Julia like a tea total or two so why is
he trying to look like a [ __ ] drug
addict I I don't know man I I don't know
man I don't know what's going on with
these people the most normal looking one
is him yeah he's dressed like some a man
of his age right he's just like
somebody's Puerto Rican Uncle exactly
looks like Bronx Johnny in 10 years
exactly that's what he looks like he
looks like what Brock's Johnny will look
like in about 10 years like yo B you
coming up to New York we gotta hang out
talk
Jay Leno I look like Jaylen dude I want
to have I think it's awesome to have
gray hair like that me too but also if
you died it would look good too ah but
don't diet that's it
you know
let's go from a Game of Thrones tried
getting out of the game she's also a an
attractive female oh she could shave her
head
now pull up rope yeah no no are they
looking a comic book character women oh
yeah because Brandon got the if you go
back a little bit I think they uh I
think [ __ ] Brendan [ __ ] up a comic
book reference
then they all start yelling at him God
he's such a [ __ ] idiot bro he said
something about this [ __ ] oh yeah go
back to where the chicks on the screen
on the bottom like the little red
everyone told me not to yeah don't keep
them yeah like well I mean
your grandma's goal weight yes that's
why my grandma swam
but she didn't realize that eating
king-sized snicker bars all the time
would that way he does look like
somebody's grandma Yeah God damn Steven
Tyler what happened but he's like 80.
looking like that though yeah [ __ ]
Jared Leto's 53 yeah but you say that
Brandon but when you're when you're his
age you're going to be trying to dress
Young And Hip too
talking about [ __ ] having Mark hardly
take down your thick boy whiskey or
whatever while you're [ __ ] sitting
there oh yeah what happened with that
eat so he lost his uh I mean did you
talk about it I mean I know you already
told me off the air until you talk about
it we mentioned a little bit but yeah
okay that's what started the mark
Crowley thing in the first hour
was just mentioning that Mark Carly runs
all his socials all right Flawless he
looks sharing to anybody I don't come on
wait he what he looks younger than
anybody in here he's 50. in that picture
but he's got makeup on and it's [ __ ]
okay okay put makeup on me bro I look
[ __ ] crazy good and he can sing I
don't know me too dude not like that bro
you want to [ __ ] Jared Leto
what the [ __ ] going on here with
Brendan 30 Seconds to Mars you do have
two handbags going on yeah I know but
put some makeup on me bro I look
fantastic okay all right wider than
Chris
not gonna lie this is it basically is
the one that brought me over but I'm
loving that would make sense did he meet
you in high school
and then all of you guys
um my name's Nicole
um I'm 26. oh too old I'm just kidding
okay you're staying for you Twilight
rocking the Grays naturally oh yeah oh
she's killed me oh yeah she's Jean Gray
from X-Men yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I was doing it fine
and then you said that I'm lying about
too old yeah she's she's Jean Gray
she's Jean Gray because does he think
that Rogue was actually named Jean Gray
because it was named after the gray
streak in her hair and not oh God he's
such an idiot probably
my name's Nicole
um I'm 26. thank you for staying for you
Twilight
rocking the Grays naturally oh yeah oh
she's 26. oh yeah she's Jean Gray from
X-Men yeah yeah or should I dye my
[ __ ] hair Vibe with me on this Jean
Gray it's Rogue
thank you Eric who had the the white
hair would you stop talking about comic
book stuff I knew it was Rogue thank you
Jean Gray did I bring up Jean Gray Nick
I think they're off
oh my God he pushes it yeah he doubles
down he never admits he's well
also I give Daddy has some grades and I
dyed it before and everyone told me not
to yeah yeah I don't I look like Jay
Leno well I mean you don't look like
Jake that's not true Jay Leno had a
bustling [ __ ] stand-up career yeah
yeah seriously and his cars the cars the
people blow him in her cooler yeah
[ __ ] seriously
dude I want to have I think it's awesome
to have gray hair like that me too but
also if you died it would look good too
ah but don't diet
the [ __ ] hair you know
let's go from a Game of Thrones tried
getting out of the game she's also a an
attractive female like she could shave
her head look at Eric by the way look at
look at look at Eric
look at his face of like I can't [ __ ]
believe this [ __ ] God God damn
it now pull up Rogue yeah no no hey
don't pull up the actors pull up the
[ __ ] the cartoon bro he's really
fighting this yeah
we ain't talking about Africa
this is what they did that's right
that's what I'm talking about
[ __ ] yeah there you go that girl's Rogue
yeah that's
oh my God I hit him
I think I'm done with this yeah I'm done
with Brendan mm-hmm
as a person